finding the right real estate
opportunity used to be incredibly
challenging
now artificial intelligence makes it
easier than ever
you see in the past you used to drive
around like a madman looking for all
sorts of beautiful real estate
opportunities suss out and subdivision
plans yada yada yada just to find out
that it wasn't feasible and you had to
do it all over again
I can actually do all of this for you
let me explain
what's going on guys my name is David
tomich I'm a registered architect here
in Western Australia and today I'm
talking all about Ai and exactly how you
can use it to enhance your real estate
investment opportunities today we're
talking about Aki star which is
basically an AI software developed by
Australians for Australians in the real
estate and architecture industry so what
is akista and what can it actually do
and more importantly what can it do for
you there are two main elements within
arkey star you can do research and
development or you can do 3D modeling
but we'll get into that a little bit
later akista is linked with all of
Australia's best real estate software
including core logic which basically
allows you to jump onto arkista 100 free
again find any single property
australia-wide and understand its
property value through core logic if
you're unsure what core logic is it's
basically what every professional real
estate agent uses to quickly assess the
value of your property now with the free
plan you do do have to go through all
the properties individually one by one
and actually assess them with the paid
plan it can find the premium
opportunities for you but we are looking
for free software so free software means
you've got to do a little bit of work
once you've found a property you like
akistar can automatically analyze the
entire thing and save you hours on end
so let's pick any property on the map
let's select it it will tell us how much
it believes this property value is worth
it's also going to break down all of the
planning policies regulations and give
us a full rundown if it's in a Bushfire
Zone flood area or even if it's impacted
by Heritage when you're developing real
estate and understanding feasibilities
all of these things are critical and it
brings them to your attention in a
matter of seconds now let's say you're a
big time developer and want to take this
block and develop it potentially two
duplexes potentially some townhouses or
maybe you're going to go to town and
build some full apartment buildings here
well traditionally speaking you'd have
to come to somebody like myself as an
architect and map this out to the full
width end try a number of different
scenarios and break it down to the best
feasible possibilities on a small block
the AI can quickly subdivide this entire
property for you and give you a
magnitude of different varieties and
scenarios so let's say you only wanted
three blocks or maybe ten blocks it can
go through all of these scenarios one by
one in seconds and give you the best
opportunity for that land this works
with duplexes townhouses and Villas of
course but this stuff is relatively
simple it becomes pretty impressive when
you move forward into those apartment
style complexes or commercial
developments so by simply changing the
parameters changing the settings you can
change this to a full apartment complex
and it will completely map it out for
you now here's where it gets actually
exciting akista not only Maps it out in
2D and shows you some generic overlays
of what is possible but in the free
trial still you have full access
accessibility to 3D Contour mapping as
well as the 3D models that it generates
now let's take a look at the duplex
model for a second you can quickly spin
around and understand what akistar is
trying to do on this block and how it is
orientated everything whilst it does its
3D modeling you can see it is
understanding the northern orientation
it is understanding the local codes the
cross ventilation the Sun and everything
in between so just like any basic
development and feasibility study that
we would do accustar is doing that for
you in a matter of seconds and if we
look at the apartment variations of this
it does an even better job it can pump
out hundreds and hundreds of different
scenarios and variations that you can
quickly flick through and change mass
and model no longer do you have to try
and figure out what the best orientation
is for this site it will automatically
do it for you based on the parameters
you adjust so what does this actually
mean for Architects Real Estate
Investors and developers the like well
basically it means you can absolutely
flood the entire market and still find
the perfect development opportunity for
you in one single day that means you
could save hundreds of thousands of
dollars and tens of thousands of hours
worth of time from research and
development all you have to do is click
on a block quickly analyze it in a
matter of seconds and move on to the
next one if it isn't right for you after
that point you can then start engaging
professional Consultants such as
Architects like myself to take this
vision and fully realize it with the
right team this AI software could make
somebody incredibly Rich anyway that's
all for me today guys thank you so much
for watching I hope you enjoyed the
video if you did there's more artificial
intelligence software available to you
just on the right hand side of me in
this playlist if you love the video I'd
appreciate it if you hit the like button
and subscribe to the channel but like
always I'll see you next Monday